So, I'm standing by the Gowanas canal, and I'm wearing
a disguise. I have on this long brown coat with the hood pulled up
the a black hat that says, "Brooklyn" on the front, I have these
big Jackie-O
sunglasses. It's overcast out. So, with the sunglasses on, I
can't really see very much, and I tell this to Esperanza. She's standing next
to me, and like, it's kind of great that I can't see with these on, right?
It makes me seem more blind.
She smiles, but it's this like sad little smile, and clearly
she thinks I'm crazy. That's because I am blind.
Even though I don't look it
it, I'm legally blind now and just getting a little more every day.
That's the whole reason Esperanza is here. She's going to teach me how to use a mobility
cane. When she first told me that we had to do the cane training in public, I totally
freaked out
out. I was like, "People are going to see me. And then it might be people I
know and, and then they're going to ask why am holding a blind-man cane, and I'm going to
have to make up like a totally
cockamamie excuse. No, I'm not doing it."
But here we are. We're standing by the canal, and Esperanza
is waiting, and I am not ready. I do not want to
take out this
cane. I have this very distinct feeling that is soon as I do, terrible
things will
happen. I'm going to lose the rest of my vision and then I'm going to be
divorced and unemployed. And they're going to take my kids away. And then, before you know it,
I'm going to be living under the Brooklyn Bridge in a cardboard box smoking crack.
I'm panicking. My heart's beating like crazy, and
my mind is scrambling. It's trying to find a way out, but
I know that I can't outrun this moment
anymore. My blindness has caught up with me.
When I was nineteen, I spent the weekend in Montauk with my boyfriend,
and we'd cuddle up at night, and he point out like the
Big Dipper and Ursa Major, and it was really weird because I couldn't see any of
them. So, it wasn't a big deal, but it reminded me of this time when I
was a kid and my father had dragged us all to Staten Island to
this beach to see Halley's Comet. He was so excited about it.
He kept calling it literally a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity. So, he had even bought a telescope, which was like
so extravagant, and my mother still complains about it twenty years later. So, he
got the telescope. It's the middle of the night. It's freezing. We're on the beach, and he sees it, and he calls us
over, but when I get up to the lens, I don't see anything.
So, when I didn't see the stars in Montauk a whole decade later,
it occurs to me that I should get my eyes checked. So, that's how I ended
up in the retinal specialist's
office. I was diagnosed with a degenerative retinal disease.
It's called retinitis pigmentosa.
The doctor said first I'd lose my nighttime vision and my peripheral vision and then eventually
my central vision, although he had no idea how long that would take. He
was hopeful I had another ten, fifteen years of decent vision
left.
A few weeks after the diagnosis, I walked into my father's study, and I found
him crying. So, I had never seen my father cry before, not even when his
parents died or his brother. So, when I found him hunched over
his desk with his glasses, off wiping his eyes, it felt very
end of days. I mean, I had known the diagnosis was not
great, but seeing him cry, I realized how
bad it was. It really seemed insurmountable.
I hated the idea that everyone would think of me as this tragic
case. I was young. I was hot. I was about to have an Ivy League diploma.
I mean, the world was my fucking oyster. So, I decided I would just
not tell people about it.
I mean, I didn't look impaired, so, you know, they wouldn't know, unless I told them.
And I decided that if my eyes were getting handed a death sentence,
I would just make them a bucket
list. So, I travelled, and I joined circus school,
and I moved to Hollywood to be a movie star. Oh, I started wearing
Russian-red lipstick
and stilettos everywhere. It was amazing. I felt like I had
changed from a caterpillar into a butterfly. Admittedly, I was a very slutty a butterfly,
but, still, I felt vital and
vibrant. Now, because I wasn't telling anyone about my eye disease, I had to
make up little stories to cover for all the accidents that I kept having.
So, when I you know, fell down the stairs of the cast party, that
was because of the champagne. And when
I couldn't find the bathroom in the dark bar, that was because I'd had one too
many cosmos. So, my M.O. was basically, "when all
else fails, plead intoxication." One night
I went to visit this
aloof hipster paramour that I'd had in Hell's Kitchen,
and afterwards, he fell asleep, but I was restless, so I decided to have a smoke
on his fire escape.
So, I get my Marlborough Lights, and I open the window, and I sling my
leg out, you know, expecting it to meet the metal of the fire escape, but it
doesn't. It just keeps going
farther and farther and farther, and then suddenly, I realized something is off. And I
jerk my body back and really quick before the balance
tips. The fire escape was out the other
window. So, I'm standing there, and I'm thinking,
"Just a few more inches, and I would be lying on Fifty-Third Street dead
or broken in some disgusting way." But that
isn't even what bothers me most. What bothers me most is the fact that everyone would think
I killed
myself because that's the only reasonable explanation
here. It's not like people fall out of fourth-floor windows even when they drink
one too many cosmos. No, everyone would think I'd kill myself,
even, you know, the people that knew about my vision
loss. And I realized I wasn't in control of
my story, and that made me really furious and
really scared, and absolutely nothing changed at
all. Really, sometimes, you know,
it takes more than a near-death experience to stop a lie from
growing. Not too long after that mishap,
I fell in love, and I got married, and I got pregnant.
When I had my son, I was twenty-seven, and I had developed cataracts in
both eyes.
So, they make everything really blurry. So, I can't really read regular print anymore.
I lose a lot of depth perception, and I go color blind, and
my tunnel vision just keeps shrinking so that even something simple, like a handshake, is
really hard because, if it isn't like directly in front of my face, it just
falls into this gaping abyss of not seeing.
Still, I didn't tell
people. It was weird, but I
just figured that I would reach a breaking point, you know, like a
moment at which my blindness would be so obvious that I couldn't cover it up
anymore. So, I had my daughter two years after I had my son, and I thought, "This is it."
But it wasn't. And then, my vision got so bad I couldn't see labels at
the supermarket or, you know, sizes on clothing or forms of the doctor's office,
and I thought, "This is it." But it wasn't.
I had gotten so good at compensating and so good at lying about it, that I was able to
just keep pushing that moment away.
So, my daughter, when she was a toddler was the kind of kid that,
as soon as her feet touched the ground, she just took off sprinting and never
looked back. She was a blind mother's worst fucking
nightmare. I would take her to the playground, and if
I looked away for like a
millisecond, she would just disappear. The problem was
there was no way for me to tell if it was like an actual emergency. So, she could
be running through the gate right into traffic, or she could just be sitting
down at my feet.
One day, we're at the playground, and I look down to check my watch, and then
I look up, and she's gone. So, instantly I'm in like a
deranged panic, and I'm panting. And I'm dizzy and I'm sweating
and
I'm calling her name in like this shrill hysterical voice.
And I'm cursing myself for being such an idiot as to look away for a second.
And I'm spinning in circles because I'm trying to find her, but I'm looking
through pinholes, so, it's really hard.
And then I hear, "Mommy!" and I look to the side, and she's there. She's right
there.
She's sitting on the bench eating goldfish. She's probably been there the whole time.
And the relief is so sudden and intense, I think for a second I might
actually throw
up. But I don't, and I sit down, and I pull or onto my lap, and I'm shaking. And I
I think, "I need a plan so that this doesn't happen again."
And for the first time, I realize I need
help because this stupid, relentless disease
will not go away, even if I ignore it and if I deny it.
And I find for the first time, something that is more terrifying
than facing my blindness, and it's much more terrifying. And it's what just happened at
the playground.
playground. So, I called the New York State Commission for the Blind,
and they sent over Esperanza to teach me how to use the mobility cane.
Ah, I told her to meet me by the Gowanas 'cause that's the most deserted area I can think of
of
and then, just to be safe, I also wear the disguise.
disguise. I mean, I'm totally going to change the error of my ways, but I have to do it
one little tiny error at a time. So, we're at the canal,
and Esperanza is waiting, and it's go time, and every fiber in me is screaming, "No, don't do
it drop the cane. Run
away!" But I think about my son, and I think about
my daughter, and I want to be a person they can
respect. And I want to be a mother that shows them they can face their problems instead
of running away from them, and I know the first step is just picking up the cane.
So, I take a deep breath, and I take off the rubber band that keeps it folded into
this little neat compact bundle,
and the cane, like, unfurls itself. All the pieces just snap
into place. It's like a magic trick. It's
so compliant, it makes me feel like it's going to make it really easy
on me, like it's been waiting for me to do this.
I take the handle in my hand, and I point the tip towards the
ground. I'm a blind woman now, and it's not pretty
or glamorous or exciting, but it's what I
am. And it feels kind of amazing to admit it.
Thanks Lou.